- So you went to the Emmy's
for the first time this year?
I did as well. It was my first time.
- I saw you.
I know, we didn't know each
other, but I saw you there.
- Well, it was my first time too.
I was a little nervous
cause I never done that.
And it was a long walk out there.
- [Brandon] It's a very long walk.
- Yeah. Did you have a good time?
- I had a wonderful time.
So I was there with my best friend
who's on "Rings of Power".
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And he was presenting as well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so we had this
incredible seat behind Oprah.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Baby, oh baby.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I left my body.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- It was crazy.
She came out.
(Terry laughing)
I've never seen a white
jumpsuit that white in my life.
(everyone laughing)
There, ay right there.
- [Terry] Ha.
- [Brandon] That's it.
- [Terry] Oh.
- Oh, y'all were at the tables behind-
- We were at the table behind, yes.
- Yeah.
- Yes, that's me contained.
I was freaking out inside.
That's me really trying to be cute.
But that white, look at that white.
You ain't never seen
white like that have you?
(crowd laughing)
- [Kelly] First of all, she
like exudes special, yeah, yeah.
- [Terry] That's a good look.
Hey, is that a pink watch
there? Is that pink watch?
- Yes. I'm actually wearing it right now.
- Oh man, that's a good looking watch.
- Yes, It's this black owned
company Spring Break Watches.
- [Terry] Yeah, that's nice.
- [Kelly] All right.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
Here's what I was nervous about.
So I'd never done the
Emmy's and I walk out
and then I was like, oh no.
Like I'd just come from
like a big shoot that day.
It was like, I came straight from there-
- [Brandon] Yes.
- From another job there
and I didn't know all the
tables were gonna be behind.
And I was like, wait, I made
sure the front looked good
but I dunno what the back looks like.
(everyone laughing)
I was like, I was like,
Oh, it's a whole lotta ass.
(Brandon laughing and clapping)
- You looked fabulous.
- I was like, well, I don't know
but I definitely wasn't
gonna be wearing white.
(everyone laughing)
I was like, Woo.
She looked beautiful.
- [Brandon] She looks so good, yes.
- [Kelly] So, yeah.